in the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit. Amen.
Though reading, from the Sinaxadion, for September 25, on which we commemorate, our righteous
Father, surges of Radhunez. The memory of our holy and God-bearing Father, surges of Radhunez,
wonderworker and protector of Russia. St. Surges was born at Rostov in the year 1314, and given the
baptismal name of Bartholomew by his parents Kiril and Maria. Even before his birth, God
indicated the future glory of his servant. One day, during the divine liturgy, before the reading
of the gospel, the child began to cry so loud in his mother's womb that other people in the church
heard his voice. And the same thing happened again, at the chanting of the Cherubic hymn,
so that his mother was afraid. At the exclamation, the holy things are for the holy, the child uttered
a cry for the third time, and his mother began to weep. When the people wanted to see the child,
she had to confess that it was not in her arms that he was crying, but in her womb.
After this unwanted event, Maria ate neither meat nor fish nor milk, but took bread and water alone
for the remainder of her pregnancy and gave herself up to prayer. When he was seven years old,
the child was sent to learn his letters, but Bartholomew did not get on at all well,
unlike his brothers Stephen and Peter, who were quick students. He was punished by the master,
teased by his classmates and rebuked by his parents, and yet for all his willingness, he did not
succeed in learning. One day when his father sent him into the fields to look for some horses,
Bartholomew caught sight of an aged monk under an oak tree, shedding tears as he prayed.
The lad went up to him quietly and waited until he finished his prayer.
What is it you want, my child? He asked.
I cannot learn anything, although I try hard, Bartholomew replied.
Pray to God for me, Holy Father, that I may be able to learn my letters.
The statets said a prayer and gave him a piece of prosphura.
Do not distress yourself, he told him. From now on the Lord will give you understanding of letters.
Seeing the statets making to go, Bartholomew fell at his feet and asked him to visit his parents' home,
adding, My parents love people like you very much, Father.
The elder smiled and went to the house of the child's parents who received him with great respect
and asked him to share their meal. Then, taking the child with him into the family chapel,
the old monk told him to read the hours. When Bartholomew replied in distress that he did not know
how to read, the statets reiterated the command and the child having taken his blessing began to
read the Psalter correctly and distinctly to everyone's astonishment. When they were again at
table the parents told the monk what had happened in church when the child was still in his mother's womb.
Before leaving them, the statets said these mysterious words.
This child is going to become the dwelling of the Holy Trinity and will bring a huge
throng of people to knowledge of his will. Bartholomew was from then on devoted to going to church
and to reading Holy Scripture. When he reached the age of twelve, he set himself to eat very
sparingly, taking nothing at all on Wednesdays and Fridays, and was content with dry bread and water
on other days. As a result of certain misfortunes that his father suffered in Rostov, the family moved
to Radones, where Bartholomew continued his ascetic path. When his two brothers married,
Bartholomew asked his parents to allow him to enter upon the monastic life, but they begged him
not to do so until their death. As it was, they both joined monasteries themselves
after a little while and died within a short time. Bartholomew prayed at their tomb for 40 days,
giving alms to the poor and had requiums served for their souls.
Then, having made up his mind to fulfill his desire, he passed over his property to his younger brother
Peter. His elder brother, Stephen, whose wife had died, made his profession as a monk at the
monastery of Kotov, where their parents were buried. Bartholomew persuaded Stephen that somewhere in
remote wild country would be more suitable for the ascetic life, so they set off in search of such a spot,
walking for miles in the forests, until they came upon a place with a source of water, six miles
from Radones and Kotov, and a long way of the beaten track. They built a cell there with a little church.
When Bartholomew asked his brother whom he regarded as his spiritual father,
which Saint, they should dedicate the Church to. Stephen, remembering the prophecy of the Stardates,
replied that it ought to be dedicated to the Holy Trinity, so the Church was consecrated with
the blessing of metropolitan Thognostus. Stephen soon found the aromitical life there too harsh,
and left to settle in the monastery of the Theophany at Moscow, where Saint Alexis,
the future metropolitan, was living. In the year 1337, when Bartholomew was 24,
Abbot Metrophonus came at his request to tonsure him a monk by the name of Serges.
Metrophonus left the young monk Serges in the forest to deal on his own with the wolves that
howled dreadfully, and with the bears that came up to his cell. One day Serges noticed a bear starving
rather than fears. He felt sorry for the animal, and gave it something to eat. The bear took a liking
to the father, and often came for its rations. The Saint always had something for it. He would share
his last piece of bread, or even go without himself, in order to feed the bear. St. Serges was on his
own like this for three years, until some men, with a serious desire for godliness, began asking to live
under his spiritual direction. One by one, twelve brethren gathered there and each built his own cell.
The midnight service, matins, the hours, and complying were chanted in the church daily.
There being no priest among the brethren, one came from outside to serve the divine liturgy.
Abbot Metrophonus, who tonsured Serges, came to live with them, but died a year later,
and the humble Serges was unwilling to become Abbot. The brethren got together therefore,
and came to him saying, Father, we cannot live without an Abbot. We want you to be our Abbot,
so that when we come to reveal our sins, you will be able to counsel and absolve us,
and besides, there is need for the liturgy to be served, so that at your pure hands, we may receive
the holy mysteries. Serges would not agree, and some days later, the brethren again met together with
the saint and begged him to accept to be their Abbot. It is not for me to fulfill the angelic
ministry. He told them, it is for me to weep for my sins. Then the brethren wept, saying,
if you are unwilling to care for our souls, we shall have to leave this place,
straying like lost sheep, and you will have to answer before God.
I would rather obey than command, Serges said, but dreading God's judgment, I will leave this
matter to the will of the Lord. Accompanied by two of the oldest monks, he made his way to Perius
Laval, to visit Bishop Athanasius of Valinia, who was in charge of the affairs of the Metropolitan
Sea during the absence of Saint Alexis in Constantinople. At the naceus had heard of the saint and
of his good deeds, and when Serges asked him to give them an Abbot, he replied, it is you who will
be Father and Abbot of your brethren, as Serges insisted on his unworthiness, the bishop said,
Beloved, you have acquired all the virtues, except obedience.
Serges bowed low before him, and soon after, in the year 1354, was ordained priest and raised
to the dignity of Abbot, pastor and physician of his spiritual brethren by Athanasius.
Saint Serges served the divine liturgy every day and was in church for the services before the others.
He made the candles and especially the prosphura, which he would always prepare with his own hands.
The number of monks remained the same for three years, until they were joined by Archimandrite
Simon of Smolensk, who had rather obeyed Saint Serges than rule elsewhere. From that time,
their numbers steadily increased. In the evening after compline, no one was allowed to go to the cell
of another monk, except the need were urgent, for the night hours had to be kept for God alone.
They spent the rest of their time in the silent alternation of prayer and manual work.
At the end of the time for the brethren to fulfill the rule of prayer in their cells,
Saint Serges would discreetly make his rounds. If he heard idle talk or laughter, he would knock on
the window and sorrowfully make his way. In the morning, gathering the culprits together,
he would put them right indirectly, speaking humbly and gently to them in parables.
He only used severity in the measure necessary towards those who refused to do penins and persisted
in their faults. He loved poverty so much that he made a strict rule of never seeking alms for
the monastery, however great the need might be. The community was extremely poor, the service was
chanted by the light of burning brands, and the books were made of birch bark. The day came when
material conditions were so wretched that neither bread nor water was to be had. When he spent
three days without eating, Serges went to find his friend Daniel and said to him,
I have heard you would like to build an entrance in front of yourself, so as to keep myself busy,
I will build it for you. It won't cost you much. I want some of the stale bread of yours.
Daniel forthwith brought him some pieces of moldy bread that he had in his cell.
Keep them until the ninth hour, the Saint told him, I am not going to take my wages before doing
the work. When he had finished his work, Sergius prayed, blessed the bread,
ate it, drank some water, and that was his meal. The brethren began complaining of the lack of food.
We are starving, the weaker among them said, and you do not let us beg alms. We are going to leave
here tomorrow, each of us will go his own way, and we will never come back. The Saint urged them to
keep up their hope in God. I am sure, he said, that God will not abandon the inhabitants of this place.
Just then there came the sound of knocking at the gate, and the porter saw that someone had
brought many loaves of bread. Full of joy he ran to the abbot and said, Father,
someone has brought us a lot of loaves. Give us your blessing to accept them.
The Saint told them to open the gates to the benefactors. He offered a service of thanksgiving and
called all the brethren to table. Where are the people who have brought us these gifts? He asked.
We invited them to eat with us, the porter answered, and asked who had sent the loaves.
They told us they had been sent by someone who loves Christ, but could not stay because they had
other work to attend to. On another occasion the Saint was praying late at night for the brethren of
the monastery, when he suddenly heard a voice calling his name. He finished his prayer, opened the
window, and saw an unusual light coming down from the sky. Surges, the voice continued,
the Lord has heard your prayer for your children. See the multitude that has gathered around you
in the name of the Holy Trinity. Thereupon the Saint saw a vast number of wonderful birds flying
within the monastery and all around it. In like manner the voice went on, the number of your disciples
will increase, and there shall not fail you men to follow in your footsteps. Not long after patriarch
Philothios sent the Saint across and other Presence with the following letter. Philothios,
by the mercy of God, archbishop of Constantinople, and ecumenical patriarch, to surges,
son in the Holy Spirit and fellow minister with our humble person. Grace, peace, and our blessing be
with you all. Word of your manner of life has reached us. We approve it, and glorify God for it,
but you lack one thing, the synabetic life. You know most Christ-like Father that the ancestor of God,
the prophet David, in whom was the perfection of spiritual understanding, praised the common life.
Behold how good and how pleasant it is for brethren to dwell together in unity.
On this account, let me advise you all that your best course will be to establish your monastery
as a synobium. The mercy of God and our blessing be with you all. St. Sergius took the advice of
the patriarch and introduced the full common life into the monastery with the blessing of
metropolitan Alexis. He put up the required buildings, established the duties appropriate to the
synabetic life, ordered everything to be held in common, and for bad the possession of personal property.
No one was to call anything his own. The number of disciples grew, and it was a time of prosperity for
the monastery. Guests were hospitably received, the poor fed, and to those who asked, homes were given.
St. Sergius took the patriarch's advice in the spirit of obedience, even though he remained the
lover of solitude. In agreeing to exercise this less flexible kind of authority, he never ceased
to be a father and preceptor, rather than an administrator. But St. Sergius was soon to suffer
cruel tribulations. One day he was in the sanctuary serving Vespers when his brother Stephen,
who had come back to the monastery, said to the canonarch, who gave you this book.
The abbot, he replied, who is abbot here, asked Stephen, was not I the first to found this place,
to which he added violent words. The saint heard all this in the sanctuary and knew this display of
anger was owing to dislike of the xenobitic life, now practiced in the monastery. Some monks, who did not
like the common life, left secretly, and others no longer wanted Sergius as abbot. Leaving those who
wanted to live according to their own will to come to terms with their consciences, the saint left the
monastery, without even going back to his cell. The better monks were uneasy, but still thought Sergius
would come back. However, they were disappointed in their expectation for the saint settled at Kigayish.
There he received a delegation sent by Saint Alexis, on behalf of those monks who wanted him to
return to the monastery, where his presence was so much needed, but Saint Alexis, aware that his
own death was near at hand, hoped to find his successor in the person of Sergius.
He summoned him to his residence and presented him with his episcopal cross, which Saint Sergius,
in all humility, would not accept. Forgive me, my Lord," he said. But since childhood,
I have never worn gold, and now I desire even more to remain in dispossession.
I know that, beloved, but accept out of obedience, replied Alexis, upon which he put the
cross around Sergius' neck, and told him that he appointed him as his successor.
Forgive me, venerable shepherd," Saint Sergius said, but you wish to lay upon me a burden beyond
my strength. You will not find in me what you are looking for. I am the most sinful and the worst
of men. At the time when the Russian people were in great fear of the totter hordes that were
sweeping through the land, the Grand Prince Demetri Donscoy, who had great faith in Saint Sergius,
asked whether he should take up arms against the godless enemy. The saint blessed the Grand Prince
for the war, and said, with God's help, you will be victorious and survive the battle safe and sound,
and covered in glory. At the time of the battle, Sergius was at prayer with his brethren,
to whom he made known the joyful issue of the fight. He even named those who had fallen and prayed for
them. So on the 8th of September, in the year 1380, just as Saint Sergius foretold, the Grand Prince
won the famous victory of Kulikovo, that marked the beginning of deliverance from the totter yoke.
One night, as he was singing the acethyst to the mother of God before her icon, and fervently
in treating her to protect the monastery, Saint Sergius broke off for a moment, to say to his
disciple Matthew, be attentive, my child, for we are about to receive a wonderful visit.
Scarsely had he uttered these words, then he heard a voice say, the most holy lady is coming.
As he tried to reach the entrance of his cell, he was all at once surrounded by a light brighter
than the sun, and saw the most holy mother of God, accompanied by the apostles Peter and John,
amid a glory greater than tongue can tell. The saint cast himself to the earth,
but the mother of God touching him with her hand said, do not be afraid.
I have chosen you and have come to visit you, for I have heard your prayer for your disciples,
and for this place. From this time forth, I shall not leave your monastery,
neither during your life nor after, but shall be its protectress.
Six months before his death, Saint Sergius called together his brotherhood,
and commended it to the care of Saint Nikon, while he gave himself to seclusion and prayer.
In September, for warned of illness, he called his brethren together once more,
and gave them his last counsels. He died in peace on the 25th of September,
in the year 1391, at the age of 78. Through the centuries, the Trinity Saint Sergius Lava
has remained the principal spiritual center of the Russian Church, and a place of pilgrimage
where great crowds assemble to venerate and to seek the intercession of the protector of the Russian
people. Through the prayers of our Holy Father's, O Lord, Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us and save us.